this is a production of Cornell
University
good so thank you very much for coming
I'm not sure if you're here for the food
or you're here to to listen to me
but I'm going to talk to you about my
favorite topic it's something which um
um when I started working in Pakistan I
kept hearing this from the extension
people the more you till the higher the
yield
and uh ever since then I've been trying
to find uh find out why if you don't do
no-till you actually have higher yields
so hopefully that's the message today
so uh let's see
how do we get these things to actually
okay so this is a just a brief outline I
want to remind everybody about what the
future challenges are for for
agriculture in the future because a lot
of you in this room are going to be
working on this in the future so I'm
retired I've done my bit
um so then I want to look at the history
and benefits the problems and
consequences of tillage the importance
of soil health I think this is something
which is going to be really important
for future
agriculture I want to look at the
definition of no-till and conservation
agriculture
um
there are different there are some new
definitions which I want to uh just to
show you what are some of the benefits
of conservation Agriculture and then I
want to show you well how did I get into
this in the first place
um and uh and then I've got a website
what I vote what have I been doing since
I uh retired okay what is life like
after Cornell
um essentially
so I like to do this I do this in my um
the classes that I used to teach uh here
we need to increase food production we
have to do it in a sustainable way and
it has to meet both food and nutritional
nutritional food security
because we have a growing population
okay maybe not in U.S maybe not in China
but we do have in other parts of the
world and at the same time we must
minimize the effects on the environment
and what I think is really important is
improving the livelihoods of those
involved in agriculture
maybe not so much in the US because you
only have a small percentage of people
involved in agriculture but if you go to
India for example you've got 20 million
farmers and uh how do we also improve
their livelihoods
um essentially the way to do that is to
improve the efficiency as this is an
agronomist I'm an agronomist I'm not an
economist not a social scientist I'm an
agronomist to improve the efficiency of
the natural resource used needed for
agricultural production how do we
improve fertilizer efficiency how do we
how do we uh do this
and we have to do this at a time when
demand for food is increasing we already
have areas of food insecurity and even
more now because of what happened with
covid
um the harvested area per capita is
diminishing
in other words we have to produce more
from a smaller area
uh traditional sources of productivity
already being used farmers are using
improved varieties they're using
fertilizer using irrigation they're
using mechanization Etc
um there's competition for water
this is a big issue uh future oil prices
we saw the spike that we had not long
ago I think in the future they're going
to become even more so and that has a
big impact on the cost of inputs
climate change we're seeing this I'm
glad I don't live in California
um where you have this this problem
there
um there's already resource
environmental and land degradation uh
the dietary changes for example in India
a lot of uh people in India would be
vegetarian but now they like to eat uh
meat and chicken
Etc and then buy a few biofuel competing
for agricultural land and more I'm sure
there are more
so I suggest that business as usual will
not get the job done so what are we
going to do about that so I wanted to
start with that that statement
so let's talk a little bit about the
history of tillage
um
essentially when hunter-gatherers
decided to be more sedentary
they would uh essentially plant their
crops with a simple planting stick make
a hole in the ground put some seeds in
and whatever comes up was fine
and then around 4000 BC you the the
farmers started using livestock manual
power uh Manpower with simple plows and
tools to uh to produce their food
I put the three sisters up there because
um the three sisters was probably one of
the first conservation agriculture
practices that you see and you all know
what that the three sisters is because
essentially they make mounds and then
they they plant corn and and into crop
with corn and legumes and squash or
pumpkins uh and then but they don't plow
it again they come back and and use that
as a a no-till system
flowers were in to invert soil 17th
century 19th century steam-powered
tractors early 20th gasoline with steel
plowed rubber wheels and then modern
tractors which we have today
not that one
so why do people do till tillage well
these are some of the reasons weed
control is one of the big ones uprooting
removing or burying you could uproot and
remove by hand or you could do it with a
hole or you could do it with uh uh with
the
tillage
oxidation of organic matter and release
of nutrients so when you when you plow
the soil you oxidize the organic matter
and this is releases nutrients which is
really important make the Surface
friable for planting or transplanting
and here's an example of rice I'm a rice
agronomist and a weed agronomist
um puddling the rice for soil puddling
is where you plow the soil when it's wet
you form a plow pan impound the water
which then helps control weeds and also
soften the soft transplanting
but this is some of the consequences of
tillage this is from Brazil
poor tillage practices uh uh you see
this erosion and essentially your top
soil and nutrients are going Downstream
or out of the ocean
here's some other consequences of this
um the one down here
shows these um a lot of this is a lot of
the top
and that is
and then of course the big example of
the problems facilities Dust Bowl I
don't want to spend a lot of time on
that but can you imagine being the
father living in that house
when this happened
so what we have is essentially you
increase tillage it's not you release
nutrients but you have an economic
organic I'm talking about organic matter
energy
um this affects the microbial
communities
hey so we reduce soil education for
drainage you get compaction and then you
you chill again so you get this spiral
[Music]
okay so now I can't move
so this is the sort of a downward spiral
of poor soil Health uh with with tillage
and it's not something that happens
overnight but over a long period of time
you see these uh this degradation
so is tillage really necessary
or as this person says are we just
burning our money
and releasing carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere
so let's talk a little bit about soil
health and this FAO book that's listed
here save and grow can you hear me
you can hold this closer
yeah
so this book at the bottom uh save and
grow has a lot of really good
information but essentially agriculture
must learn to return to its roots by its
rediscovering the importance of healthy
soil
um drawing on natural sources of plant
nutrition and using mineral fertilizer
wisely and then there's a statement
there I won't spend time on it but
essentially a healthy soil I have some
slides I want to show on that so the
importance of soil health
and this was uh the the director of USDA
uh in 2019 he says when we restore the
soil we see an improvement in quantity
and quality of food
and then the whole goal is to take
agriculture to the next level uh and
this will require Creative Solutions and
collaboration between everyone touched
in agriculture
so if you look at a a degraded soil this
is some of the properties all physical
properties problems of water
infiltration more pathogens nutrient
deficiencies
Etc
whereas a healthy soil be higher in
organic matter and has some of the
opposite effects of what you see on the
left
so a forest soil for example where you
have it's not Disturbed and it has leaf
mulch or it has mulches on the ground
this this is what you find with uh with
a if you sample a forest soil
but the one on the left intense
intensively mined agricultural soil no
organic amendments essentially
and I have this
this uh just says you know no addition
of organic matter with the Green
Revolution it worked really well for a
while until you decreased the organic
matter in the soil that affected the
soil biology
Etc and so what we need is is a
combination of both organic matter and
and chemical fertilizer
um so this is on this side
present farming practices now I'm not
just talking about the US I'm talking
about global my experience is mostly in
South Asia
and this is a healthy soil using organic
amendments minimal soil disturbance uh
and some of these other other important
important things rotations
so I will be talking about conservation
agriculture
and if we go through
uh so our biological diversity I think
if any of you have taken Janice's course
um you've already gone through this and
if you haven't taken it take it because
it's really going to be important in the
future but essentially what you're
trying to do is improve the bio
biodiversity of the soil in terms of
microbes
and a healthy soil has more microbes
than an unhealthy soil I also have a
video called life in the soil which I
like to look at when I saw that video it
was done by a Japanese group I began to
understand why this was so important it
was something that was going on below
the soil surface you couldn't see it
but it was really important
okay
and what what I'm going to hypothesize
is that conservation agriculture which
I'm going to describe soon plays a
critical role in below ground diversity
and disease and past suppression
so the big question is you can talk
about it and in fact Cornell uh our
department soils and crop science has a
really excellent program on soil health
and you can measure it but how do you
improve it
so that's the question question how do
you improve soil health
and I want to just go back to a little
bit on sustainable Crop Production
intensification the Green Revolution
Paradigm I saw disturbance modern high
yield varieties High purchased input use
and we got good higher yields and higher
output it helped to essentially prevent
famines that occurred in the 30s and 40s
and 50s you don't hear as many of these
families who do today the downside is
that there was pollution Farmers used
too much fertilizer reduced efficiency
loss of soil Health erosion and and and
and side effects so what we really need
to be doing in the future is sustainable
intensification Paradigm I use the word
responsible because I can't always
Define what sustainability is
but I can I can Define to you what I
think is responsible
strengthen soil health and natural
processes to boost production
um and environmental services avoid
waste input use only as much as the
system will take and improve the
efficiency of Natural Resources
there are a number of new definitions
everybody seems to want to have a new
definition every year or two or three
years you get a new definition so
climate smart agriculture came out about
10 years ago our regenerative
agriculture is there now agroecological
farming I'm not going to spend time on
this there is a link on my program which
will take you to these definitions
and that there are others all I contend
is that if you're talking about soil
health and you're talking about uh from
an agronomic point of view conservation
agriculture would be involved somewhere
in all three of those
they never mentioned it but it's that's
what they do so let's talk about
um mechanized no-till
the Dust Bowl
use of inversion tillage led to the this
what happened is that the scientists and
the soil scientists came up with the
term conservation tillage conservation
tillage was reduced tillage with a
chisel plow and stubbles were left on
the soil surface about 30 so that was
the beginning of no-till beginning of
conservation agriculture uh the
Forerunner of no tillage farming
1943 I'm not sure that um
our Dutch friend is here today
um but um he always in his class uh
talks about plowman's Folly this book is
in the library if you want to read it
no one has ever Advanced a scientific
reason for for plowing
okay there's simply no need for plowing
in the first instance and most of the
operations that costs customarily follow
the plowing are entirely unnecessary if
the land has not been plowed there is
nothing wrong with our soil except our
interference so this is uh this is I'd
like to use this is to say hey think
about it don't don't reject no-till uh
24d herbicide that came out in 1940s
helped to control weeds a lot of people
say well no-till you have a weed problem
uh so it doesn't work
well that's a good opportunity for weed
scientists to find Solutions on how to
resolve the weed problem
research and testing of no-till in all
continents from 1960 to 2000 and limited
scaling with farmers in 1980s and 1990s
okay so it's not very far away still in
my lifetime
and by 2000 there was about 65 million
hectares of no-till cropland systems in
in the world
now I want to switch over the
conservation agriculture
um I call this an ecosystem approach to
regenerative sustainable agriculture
um from 1970 to 97 there was a lot of
farmer experimentation a lot of research
being done in various parts of the world
to Define what are the key components of
a sustainable no-till system
in 1997 meeting in Mexico these two
people were very well known in the
conservation from FAO came up with the
definition
conservation agriculture so we're
talking about 1998.
that's not too long ago
and essentially what the three pillars
of conservation agriculture is little on
those sold disturbance
okay no-till or no just enough to get
the seed into the soil
uh permanent soil cover that's really
important and this can be residues of
the previous crop or it can be cover
crops and I should also point out that
conservation Agriculture no-till and
cover crops is becoming a big uh uh
thing to get into importance to Farmers
uh
and they provide some of the uh some of
the things don't burn the residue
okay
the easiest thing to do is to get a box
of matches and pile up some of the straw
and and light it and the next thing you
know everybody's uh
having to wear masks not for covid but
because of air pollution
and then crop rotation and later the
diversity of crops now what you find is
that some Farmers just do one of those
they might just do no-till
some of them realize afterwards that no
till Plus cover crops Plus or residue
leaving residues is really important and
I'm going to show you some slides on
there
and then rotation may come in later on
okay so so a lot of people criticize
well conservation you know they only do
one of these so therefore conservation
is no good so and this is one of the
sources uh this is in a new Journal
called Agronomy not the American Society
of agronomy Journal
um experiences and lessons from concert
conservation agriculture
so they have this picture
you can see the Dust Bowl in 1930 so
around 1950 1970 you see this big
increase in conservation agriculture or
no-till agriculture to where in 20 20
well over 200 million hectares of
no-till in the world at the moment okay
and
2022 it's probably up around 220.
and where is that
here the data one of the big problems
with getting data on conservation
agriculture is not collected by the
national programs
so you have to find other ways of
getting this information but you can see
the main areas in South and Central
America May mostly Brazil Argentina a
very big no-till countries and you can
see the changes that have occurred since
2008-9 uh in the third column and then
how much a percentage of the ca air in
the region in 2018-19
some of them are still fairly small look
what happened in Ukraine it was very
small in 2008 but it became uh much
bigger in in 2018
um
six million hectares because it's
probably none there at the moment so
but I want to also raise this that it
doesn't solve all problems there's no
Panacea it's just a way of helping to
improve don't forget all of the other
modern or good activities that are
needed for producing food things like
good genetic stock good potential good
uh these things
integrated in other words minimum soil
disturbance saw cover and pop diversity
and not you need to also do all of these
other things
integrated approaches to Pest Management
nutrient management weed management
Etc
uh mechanization permanent bed and
photos by the way conservation
agriculture can be done on the flat or
it can be done on beds or it can be done
in basins
so sustainable Crop Production aims to
maximize options for crop production and
intensification while minimizing the
effect on biodiversity and ecosystem
services
and we also need to think of livestock
in here as well
so
no tillage it's called many things in
different parts of the world so in
Brazil it might be uh
siembra director but it it's a rapidly
growing practice in the world
but notice the residue cover the residue
cover is one of the most important
aspects of this
some of the benefits I've listed a lot
of them there uh I've highlighted
increased soil biolog biological
activity uh erosion
infiltration of water there's a number
of things there but I think the last one
reduced labor and costs are the main
things that motivate Farmers to
experiment with this technology
okay because one of the important things
with any technology the farmers have to
adopt it if it's going to have any
impact on food security
and so I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on that today but how do you get
Farmers to practice this it's very easy
to take a bag of seed and say hey this
is a better variety
that's very simple but try doing it with
a a technology like a complex technology
like uh like this
so I wanted to show this picture
this is in Australia left hand side
no-till right hand side conventional
right notice
there's 35 more infiltration of water on
the left hand side
it's counter-intuitive right you do
tillage so you get better infiltration
of water
well actually the textbooks are wrong on
that
on the right hand side see how that
water is ponding
and what's happening is that water's
running off and causing the problems of
top soil loss but notice the residue is
still there on the left hand side
and if you look at the same field at
Harvest Time
on the left hand side you see the
no-till maze
and on the right hand side you see where
the conventional tillage so we have a we
actually have a maze crop and some some
yield on the left hand side and zero
yield maize on the right hand side
and it's all due to essentially uh
infiltration of water and this was just
drought stress
and I've got the same thing from cement
I worked at Summit Wheaton maze Center
uh no-till plus residue and this is a
long-term trial so this is maybe after
uh you know 10 years or 15 years of
doing no-till and residue in this plot
and this is without residue no-till same
no-till but this is without residue so
you
you really need that residue to help
with the surface to allow infiltration
of water to work with the soil biology
Etc
and the same thing happens on wheat
this is no-till without residue this is
until now no-till without residue what
they did is they burnt the residue
so burning residue is not a not a good
idea so sometimes people say well
no-till is no good see look you get
lower yields well it takes time to get
this let me see and no-till does not
equal conservation agriculture you need
the the the residue
so here's a picture in uh of soybeans in
Brazil after wheat
um here's another picture from uh Zambia
or a graduate student from our
department went there and what you see
down here is um let's see down the base
space of the base of the the maze Parts
they've actually Dug Dug a basin
and in that Basin they put some organic
matter in and they planted Maize but
they could also plant into crop with
some legumes as well and what we
recommended is that after they harvest
this is don't dig those again but make
them permanent permanent basins
and therefore all of the improvements in
the soil quality and this is a practice
from from uh from North Africa
is this is a traditional system
so small or big farms can do this
tractor to manual or animal power mono
or mixed cropping trees can be added
irrigated or rain fed flat or raised bed
planting basins or Mounds depending on
whether you have a problem with drainage
the three sisters is an example of uh of
a mound a mound system
here's a picture in in East Africa of
these uh trees being put in and this is
a leguminous tree some of the farmers
will actually Lop off some of the um
some of the branches and use that as
fertilizer
so he's taught what about resource
Farmers you know average Farm size in
India is about one hectare a couple of
Acres
um how do how do these they can't afford
to have a tractor how are they going to
do this this work
um they have these various things they
don't have enough money
um uh lack of income they they don't
want to they don't want to take the risk
associated with new technology what we
recommend is the use of service
providers and this is what has happened
in India in some of these countries
service provider you take a young person
provide him with the equipment that he
needs and then he comes to the farmers
and essentially does the the the the the
no-till and the residue into the residue
for that farmer he may even be able to
provide some of the inputs and some of
the thing for forfeit
and in fact a lot of the farmers in in
South Asia would do their plowing that
way
a farmer who had a tractor in the
village would do the first plowing or
the second plowing
um uh and they did it on the same so who
were the biggest opponents for no-till
uh when we went into South Asia where
those Farmers that had tractors that got
income from the tillage
but we soon convinced them to actually
switch over when I say we I meant the
national programs and the scientists and
the people that we worked with
okay
the other thing which is really
important is that you need an innovation
Network to get the adoption you need to
local manufacturing local Machinery
makers and developers public sector
extension and universities
non-government extension groups
scientists Innovative Farmers credits
etc etc
this doesn't work so let me take this
off
okay
so you need a really this has to be
developed at the same time so you see
it's not a simple thing it's not
something which you can come in with a
bag of technology and say okay now adopt
this you have to get all of these actors
involved in stakeholders and the way we
did it in South Asia is by having what
we call champions in their country who
were able to to get all of this thing
happening
policy and institutions is also really
important this comes from the same save
and grow book from FAO to encourage
smallholders to adopt sustainable car
production fundamental changes are
needed in development policies and
institutions and there's some a list of
some of the things it has to be
profitable to the farmers otherwise they
uh they're not going to benefit from it
and also the enabling factors that need
to be in place to allow Farmers to
experiment with new ideas
foreign
so let's go back to when I first got
into Pakistan
okay that was in the 1980s
and this is a graph that shows the
importance of planting date
right so if you look at this there's a
sort of a optimal planting date this is
wheat following rice
read following race and you can see that
about November 15th is the best date for
planting the planet a little bit earlier
uh you have problems with uh it being
too hot uh if you plant late what
happens is that
the plants the the wheat matures at a
time when the heat increases and you get
uh uh shriveling of grains and lower
yields by planting on time you can
escape
that heat stress and of course heat
stress is going to be more important
with climate change in the future
we now we could say the national program
breeders Palm breeders have now got
varieties of wheat that can be planted
as early as the end of October
without yield loss
and so therefore uh have higher yields
so we did a diagnostic survey in this
area we were getting low yields farmers
were planting their their wheat in
December and even in early January
and so late planting reduces wheat yield
that was the main main thing and there
were several reasons one of the reasons
was while the previous crop got
harvested late
um or they grew another crop before they
planted wheat or they had long duration
varieties there were a number of number
of factors some of those you can take
care of uh change the rice varieties
although that's not so easy
um and uh Etc then below but one of the
big things was the long turnaround time
from when rice was harvested and wheat
was planted
and the reason for that was excessive
tillage some Farmers pla actually plowed
20 times
because the saws were fairly had very
poor structure and they needed to they
they wanted to turn it into talcum
powder for planting
um or and that got rid of a lot of the
moisture or there was too much moisture
um or they were threshed of rice before
they wanted to do this plowing or they
were power constraints okay
so that's where we came up with what why
do they do it tillage can you imagine uh
plowing with a Bullock and a wooden plow
and having to walk uh up and down the
field 20 times to get tillage you can
imagine how much so we we had a a New
Zealand uh manufacturer of equipment
come to Pakistan and one of the key
components with this uh this Colter this
opener
inverted t uh open it and you see what
they did is the local manufacturers were
able to put this put this opener on
their drills
they could then plant into the residue
um with uh and apply both seed and
fertilizer so you had better
distribution of fertilizer more
efficient use of fertilizer
and this was good for fields for
harvested by hand so when in 1980s a lot
of the rice fields were harvested by
hand
okay so then you had anchored anchored
straw and this this didn't cause any
problems but then
as the 90s 2000s came along people
started to have uh service providers
doing combine harvesting
combine harvesting was leaving a lot of
loose residue on the surface so this
this system didn't work
but then the engineers in that area said
okay well how do we overcome that and
here's a simple John Blackwell from
Australia came up you can see the
no-till drill at the back and the back
here and then what this does pick up
picks up the straw
you plant in in uh you know where
there's no loose residue and then the
straw is put back down on the on the
cell surface
okay
so
what about the US well a couple of
things there's a lot of farmers and a
lot of organizations in the US that are
now doing no-tilling and this no-till
farmer magazine is something which you
might like to to look at and in this
magazine you also see uh
manufacturers of some of the implements
for working on cover crops or residues
loose residues in that area
and and places like South Asia and India
and China there's a lot of local
manufactures of equipment
um so you see in California there's a
lot of uh conservation agriculture now
being practiced there a lot of cover
crops being covered uh used there so
it's growing okay
this is what we want to prevent
you may have heard about in New Delhi
you could hardly breathe you had to stay
inside your house because it got so
thick with with the smoke that it was
dangerous for your health
and also a lot of that residue would
fall on the glaciers up in the up in the
Himalayas and then increase the Albedo
to where the the snow actually melts
faster now than it did before so how do
we how do we overcome this well we think
no-till uh is is the way to go and leave
that residue on the ground as your
resident cover
okay so what have I done since 2015 I
retired in 2015. I can't believe it was
seven years ago but when you retire it
doesn't mean to say you become a couch
potato okay so what I've been doing is I
uh curate maintain a conservation
agriculture website with Lucy Fisher
um I'll see if I can get this one to
work this is my website
um if you look at this website if you go
to here you look at the full research
database
this is what I spend most of my time on
at the moment you've all used zotero
and in soltero if you go to um if you go
to the conservation agriculture articles
I have
2870 articles now in that database and
I'm adding to them everywhere every
month it's incredible how much how much
research has been done in this
particular field at the moment
and I also have key keywords I have the
DOI number I have the um the the
articles there if you need to get them
but you can find them at Cornell
um so I think I better stop there so we
can have some questions
I also put out a a newsletter and some
of you get my newsletter uh Stupid
newsletter where I pick the best
articles every month and send it out to
list serves and to various people
okay
the obvious question is what about the
plant diseases what about the Plant
Pathology you talk about weed control
but isn't that a serious problem with a
residue well
one of the interesting things is that
that's what you would expect right it's
what I do expect that's what you you
expect but actually in what what you
find is that if you can increase the
biological diversity in the soil
those or those organisms actually can
help control some of the parasitic uh
organisms
okay so talk to the people in Australia
talk to the people where this is
happening
um you do see cases of where you have
more disease more
um
wheat diseases for example in some
Fields I was thinking of rusts and smuts
and things like that Russ is not one I
would worry about the rust is one that
has carried from the air and it's in you
know you you that's why you have to use
good germ plasma and plant you you're
going to have rust diseases
but then you know that what one of the
interesting things about the Green
Revolution was the varieties that were
developed by cement or by Norman borlag
and that had very very good rust
resistance uh and that's why so you you
you you use integrated disease
management
use varieties that have resistance
but it's not something you can ignore I
agree yeah
yes
I was just going to ask a follow-up
question I might hypothesize and I
wonder if you had experience with this
the disease issue which I think comes up
a lot with revenues do you think that
might interact with the moisture regime
and how the moisture changes over time
climate change like in Upstate New York
maybe maybe in California right now if
you have a lot of water on that residue
you might have a very different
condition than maybe in Australia where
maybe most of the time is dry I would
imagine the microbes was paved very
differently in the two systems
yeah there's a lot of articles in the
database that I have that look at that
one of the interesting things when you
have the residue and do no-till is you
get much better infiltration of water
you have actually have more more Waters
sitting and ponding on the surface uh
with plaque with tillage and so then you
would have certain diseases that would
come up so I don't I
when you see 200 million hectares
it's obviously you know I don't think
it's as big a problem as you think but
if it is a problem then you need to then
and have a client Pathologists in your
program and you must have user
integrated uh disease management as part
of the so don't don't ignore that if you
have a weed problem you need to look at
integrated weed management rather than
just use a herbicide yeah
yes early instances you have regions or
particular crops where this would not be
appropriate and we do not be recommended
and there's still a constipation system
ah
I don't think so
um one of the big challenges is if you
start looking at Rice
but the problem with rice is that when
you do the puddling and you do the
transplanting first of all it uses a lot
of water it destroys the soil physical
properties of the soil may have some
impact on other properties of the soil
and and it's a very labor intensive and
costly so a lot of farmers are now
having problems finding people to do the
transplanting or do the puddling and
then the crop that follows that puddle
of soil is not very good so there's a
movement to go to direct seeded rice
right when you go to direct seeded rice
the first challenge
so you have to overcome the weed problem
but what we're finding what what when I
say we what is happening in the National
programs I've left 20 years ago uh they
are coming up with Solutions using
integrative weed management to overcome
that problem so even rice if you have
rice no-till followed by wheat no-till
you have a much healthier soil and a
much higher yield but there are problems
uh problems of phosphorus there are
problems of some of these other
nutrients so you need integrated
nutrient management I don't see any
reason why you don't have to do
intensive tillage I think you can do
away with a minimum
yeah
right here
um just looking ahead a little bit so
um there's about two and a half
which is increasingly
demanded for public transportation
it's just you know the resource I was
just wondering if there's any ways to
actually
be up to harvest up as a resource of
service and the benefits of the
professional attention the other aspects
of
conservation agriculture if you see that
teaches
it is possible
um I do see with with the no-till first
of all you don't not burning the diesel
for the land preparation
you're also finding with the mulch on
the surface that you're increasing the
organic matter in the soil
now there's a lot of papers now that
show that you increase too much but if
you don't need batteries and you take
that resources
[Music]
well I don't think that you should be
growing biofuels on an agricultural land
foreign
there is the whole issue of carbon
carbon credits for uh this but I don't
see how when you've got 20 million small
holder farmers in India how are you
going to get payments for for you know
Carbon sequestration uh but it's but you
know that's something that you're in
that area and so you go keep your job
and the other students associated with
you they can look at that issue
all I'm saying is that we have a big
problem with tillage system that we have
you see that for example if you're
either burning
the recipe
because
it's simple but you know you know but
also a lot of times the residue will be
expected
it is
um foreign
[Music]
and so when you sometimes look at say a
long-term experiment that is based on
the ideal system where the residue goes
back and then you look at practice where
a lot of farmers remove the residue and
nothing is nothing but bite that's it
folks are very different situation
no-kill without the restroom is very
different and what's inheritance
residue management is also a very key
important and you have to be aware of
the fact that farmers have animals and
they need to be fed so you have this
competition so you so but can you come
up with something where you have some of
the residues go to feed your animals and
some of it goes to feed the soil
you know so
I mean it's not it's a very complex
complex issue yes do you have a question
yeah um
all right now I'm going into a piece of
computers uh because we're having sort
of washing problems and some people
saying that this will help with private
information
what I've heard is not that
I've heard that farmers that said I've
tried rotational tillage but found I
didn't need it
and they continue with no-till but once
again I'm I can't be everywhere so
that's what that's something to look at
I actually I think with no-till with
residue retention you actually have less
subsoil hard pans and and compaction the
compaction comes when you do tillage
yeah so I I
you're from there go and talk to some of
the farmers there and ask them uh you
know some farmers down there have been
doing it for 30 40 years
and what the farmers say there the
biggest problem was this
in in adopting it the mind
that you know your father say you know
my utilize yield and my grandfather did
it so but now they they do it now the
big problem is that they are now using
they have to use say they have been
using herbicide tolerant crops like
soybeans and Maize with glyphosate and
that so there are some issues in that
respect so
thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu